lethal weapon you shoot that here at
Warner Brothers yeah right but you also
shoot it we're down in Long Beach I mean
we kind of shoot all over I've heard
you've been doing some exteriors and
that and some location shoots and that
that you had a little bit of an incident
yeah yeah we were shooting in Long Beach
and I think one of the guys came up and
said it was like we're on eight o'clock
and they're like yeah we're gonna call
it a wrap
I was like yeah awesome short day it was
like 13 hours a day of work and but I
said why why were you wrapping at Lee's
like somebody stole Damon Wayans his
character's car I was like wait these
stole his car like in front of everybody
and they think there's like 50 crew guys
standing around or Union guys standing
around this car that he uses on the show
someone just took off in it I stole it
yeah of course everybody afterwards is
like - where's your car but then the
next day the guy who stole it drove by
the set again what yeah the cop has got
awesome but then the cops found him got
into a I guess high-speed crash caught
him wait wait a minute he steals the car
but then comes back the next day and
it's a it's a car that's on a TV show so
it's famous and he's cruising by like
taunting you yes it's awesome like just
okay it's I love it - everything is just
like that's awesome that's pretty cool
yeah now you're playing a tough guy role
now yeah
is that any of that come from you are
you a tough guy in real life no not at
all
I do not know I'm the [ __ ] yeah a big
one I mean the other day was cuz he
liked to road bike right yeah like a
cycle so I was cycling on PCH I don't
like snakes at all I'm like Indiana
Jones that way and I saw a rattlesnake
it was like that big I mean was maybe
like a little baby he's like a big worm
yeah and I almost threw up and had the
whole ride I kept thinking at the snake
somehow got attached to my tire and was
working its way up
[Laughter]
that was terrifying yeah so so no I'm
not I have had the same I have to tell
you I go out on my bike and I like to
mountain bike too and I go up and
there's have been a bunch of times where
I've passed a rattlesnake on my you know
mountain bike and I've thought I haven't
thought maybe they're gonna climb up on
the bike yeah but I have thought that
they're gonna like leap up they can do
that they can do that I think so you
have no authority they can do that
really not sure yeah it's a scary
thought though I don't know what will
bike together next time and we'll both
be killed
you